hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to you
know Hollywood has a talent for taking
symbols of our cherished childhood and
smashing them and two indescribable
amounts of people matter and nowhere is
that more prominent than in the horrors
of the Super Mario Brothers movie the
game about two Italian plumbers who
rescue a princess from a dragon was such
a huge hit that they put it on
everything
candy magazines comic books the works so
it only figured to put together Super
Mario Brothers movie as quickly as
possible and when we saw the trailer for
this movie we realized it wasn't just
Super Mario Brothers it was Super Mario
Brothers on steroids I'm serious dude
this movie was packed with flamethrowers
rocket boots giant monster than a
badass-looking city
so naturally we got hyped it was opening
day there were lines around the block
and we were ready to see the badass
action film of the year we sat down to
our seats and the film began all right
the traditional Mario music this is
gonna be just like the game a long long
time ago the earth was ruled by
dinosaurs they were big so not a lot of
people went around hassling them you
know it just don't get no better than
this then a giant meteorite struck the
earth
goodbye dinosaurs what if the dinosaurs
weren't all destroyed what if the impact
that that meteorite created a parallel
dimension where the dinosaurs continued
to thrive and evolve into intelligent
vicious aggressive beings and hey what
if they found a way back
oh my god this movie's gonna blow so
let's see what's wrong with this horse's
ass of a movie well for starters the
graphics in the game are actually better
than the graphics in the opening that
strike one
coop as a human being instead of a
dragon that strike two and two Italian
plumbers are played by a British man and
a Latino and that's strike three you
know what the hell five minutes into
this movie already has three strikes
against it this is going to suck ass
alright so the film centers around a
love story between Luigi and the only
good-looking archeologists in the entire
world Daisy
the chemistry is about as awkward as Tom
Cruise and I guess anyone he's dated I
want to apologize right now in case when
when I start get to get talking and I
start to say things that sound really
weird
don't worry Luigi it's not you it's just
bad writing
upon taking her out to dinner we find
out that the Mario Brothers aren't even
brothers at all they're father and son
Mario he Umbro me up but wait a minute
doesn't Mario specifically at one point
say Mario Brothers bluntly and isn't the
title of the stinking movie so wait what
are you trying to say they're they're
father and son and brothers he's been my
my mother of my whole life
your messed up movie your fucking messed
up so after that incestuous moment we
find that Daisy is abducted and taken to
a parallel world where humans evolved
from lizards instead of evolving from
monkeys suck on that creationism and in
the horrifying city of name not
announced there's an evil tyrannical
source Rex known as King Koopa played by
Dennis Hopper only he doesn't breathe
firing four hammers like in the
videogame no this coupe is more like a
mix between Donald Trump and dr. evil
see you later alligator Disney's
Reluctant dragon would have been scarier
than this how die his plan is to merge
our two dimensions together in de-balled
mankind he does this by using a rock
from a meteorite that hit earth
thousands of years ago that day see
apparently keeps around her neck or some
shit like that I don't know I'm usually
asleep at this point stupid
his evil henchmen in this movie are
creatures known as goombas and I have to
admit I honestly think they went out of
their ways to make sure these creatures
look nothing like the original game it's
like they're trying to piss us off yeah
bet names not really
last name whoa whoa we're gonna hear
Mario's last name dude we'd never hurt
Mario's last name before this I'll be
interesting oh cool all right so uh
what's Mario's last name Mario yeah I
know what's your last name not really no
no what's your last name Mario
no okay what's your first name Mario
right now what's your last name
Mario fuck you what's your first name
Luigi and what's your last name
Mario shop what's your last name Luigi
Mario those are both first names what's
your last name
Mario shut what's your full name we do
Mario those are Hoover okay
what's your first name Luigi and what's
your last name Mario what's your full
name we do Mario what is this an Abbott
and Costello routine my Oh Mario and
Luigi Maya are you fucking kidding me
they couldn't think of last name so they
just gave them their first names again
that's like something a kid writes
family doesn't know the
on a test Oreos last name is sir Mario &
Luigi's last name is Mario - because
they're brothers you see wait no no no
father and son now one of the things you
might be asking yourself is why in this
version as opposed to the game is it
Luigi that ultimately gets the hot
princess booty I mean who does that
leave Mario with Wow whoa boy sorry
Mario but our princess is in another
White Castle
unfortunately the Duchess of Dairy Queen
also has the rock and steals it from our
heroes which unfortunately means a lot
of these shots the only way to get it
back is for Mario to use his bowling
Italian charm to seduce er what some
people will do for a role sadly though
most of the performances in this movie
are downright terrible I mean I love Bob
Hoskins but half the time it sounds like
he's coughing up a hairball hey party's
already outta here and every time I hear
that New York accent I keep expecting
Roger Rabbit to pop up but by far the
biggest award for killing a performance
goes to the pooper scooper Koopa and so
Dennis Hopper it's literally like he
woke up every morning and just said to
himself I'm not going to act today I
don't know what I'm going to do but it's
not going to be acting in fact we
haven't seen Dennis Hopper in a while
halfway but what do you expect when
you're in movies that have you sang
lines like let's hear that again and
this is why you don't see Dennis Hopper
anymore in fact if you watch it in slow
motion you can actually pinpoint the
moment where his career implodes in on
himself but
there is no other line in this movie
that could destroy an actor's career so
quickly monkey okay maybe one other one
in fact let's see those two back-to-back
our monkey monkey monkey monkey monkey
monkey monkey the only thing that's kind
of cool about this movie is the way they
teleport from one world to another it's
not a great effect but it's pretty
inventive way to consider it comes from
a city covered in shrooms ah
I'll shut up and say baa baa ah so on
top of the bad acting in the lame story
line there's several lines dialogue that
are just entirely pointless for example
there's a strange running joke where
Koopa tries to order a pizza
I'd like the Koopa special pterodactyl
tail on that yes Dino lizard hold the
mammal no worms and spicy okay not funny
prepare my destiny where's my pizza okay
it's still not funny sorry your pizza's
here not now looks like I win and all
together not funny so the final
conclusion we have to draw from this is
not funny plus not funny not fucking
funny people have to go back to film on
a one if you want a joke to work you
need humor don't know Jesus I can't
imagine this film getting any worse I
know this is gonna sound a little
strange but I want you to meet my father
well it's an honor to meet you sir in a
play and I just I just want to thank you
for all your help
okay I'm gonna wrap this up before I
puke the Mario Brothers get the rock
back stop the evil Koopa turn him into a
muppet and return back home
Daisy can't go because she has to figure
out where she belongs and they have
themselves a happy ending or do they
Luigi Mario what's wrong you're never
gonna believe this
I believe it you do
I believe and I'm not kidding this is
where it ends
on a fucking cliffhanger Oh what's wrong
how does Mario know what's wrong why
does Daisy have a flamethrower
well thank heavenly Jesus we'll never
find out the answer to those questions
Super Mario Brothers bombed at the box
office and thus never had a crappy
Hollywood sequel where did the Vice guys
concentrate on botching up the first
shitty s movie before you start thinking
up ideas about how to fuck up the next
one perhaps the biggest surprise of the
movie is the fact that somebody actually
wrote it not one but three people
actually played a part in putting this
together and would you believe that this
movie actually had two directors because
one director can't possibly make a film
this battle oh it takes two with
concerted effort but to their credit
could you imagine anyone else that could
possibly direct a superior film a monkey
it's got me there I'm the Nostalgia
Critic I remember it so you don't have
to